the biden administration continues to
push forward
with its attempts to spend more money
than god has ever seen
the other day yesterday the the
congressional budget office came up with
an estimate of how much joe biden's
buildback better plan would actually
cost if it weren't filled with laws so
the buildback better plan was
essentially altered in a in a pretty
obviously dishonest way they created
false sunsets for programs what they did
is they said okay well what if we put in
place a child tax credit but for only
the next two years
the reason they're saying that is
because if it were estimated over the
next 10 years it would cost a lot of
money
so it's sort of like
buying a subscription to a magazine and
saying i'm going to allow to expire
three years from now but meanwhile you
know you're not going to allow it to
expire three years from now you know
it's going to go for 10 years and that
is what they're doing with buildback
better so build back better they set up
these false sunsets they know are never
going to actually apply and then they
say well it's only going to cost a
certain amount of money no
it's not so cbo analyzed what exactly
would the bill cost if all of these
programs became permanent and it turns
out it would cost something like four
bills four to five billion if sorry four
to five trillion dollars over the course
of the next 10 years
and this of course is very bad for
jensaki and the white house and joe
biden and all because
there are still democrats in the senate
who are going to have to go home and
explain to their voters why they voted
for a bill that is going to increase the
national debt by trillions and trillions
of dollars so jinsaki's immediate
response was to call it fake news now
i'm old enough to remember
when a press secretary calling things
fake news was a full frontal assault on
the journalistic establishment who's a
threat to freedom of the press i'm old
enough to remember when if donald trump
had said about the cbo that it was
filled with people who are making fake
analyses that would be an attack on our
institutional integrity here in the
united states
now the bite administration does this
routinely and everybody sort of shrugs
here's jen saki going after the
cbo where you're talking about here is a
fake cbo score that is not based on the
actual bill that anybody is voting on
this was a
ask request by senator graham to score a
bill that is not currently being debated
and the president has conveyed very
clearly multiple times publicly that he
would like programs if they're extended
to be paid for that remains his
commitment but it's important to
understand that when you when anybody
raises a question about this new cbo
score it is a fake score about a bill
that doesn't exist
oh so it's a fake score about a bill
that doesn't exist but which would exist
if you guys weren't lying about what
you're doing right now it's not an
attack on the press when democrats say
it it's not an attack on the cbo when
democrats do it when democrats attack
the supreme court it's not an
institutional attack when democrats
attack the filibuster it's not an
institutional attack when mitch
mcconnell doesn't vote on merrick
garland for the supreme court it's an
institutional attack that's the way this
stupidity works well the good news is
joe manchin remains not on board with
buildback better here was joe manchin
yesterday saying yeah the inflation
threat is real it is not transitory and
everybody who's saying differently is
lying to you
i think it would be very transparent for
the puppy to see exactly what they'd be
getting for what we're spending for 10
years so you won't support it these
programs are temporary we're going to
talk we're still talking i'm just you
know i'm listening to everybody but you
know i'm just telling you ask me about
inflation israel it's not transitory
uh it's alarming it's going up not down
joe manchin's body language here is no
no and no which it should be considering
that joe biden is one million points
underwater in his home state of west
virginia if joe manchin wishes to retain
his job he's not going to be voting for
buildback better
according to the new york times he is
the most prominent democratic holdout on
biden's 2.2 trillion social safety net
climate and tax bill that of course is
not the real price it's more like five
trillion he casts fresh down on monday
on his party's plans to speed the
measure through the senate before
christmas saying he still had grave
concerns about how it would affect the
economy
he said anything is possible he said he
was still engaged but it is very
unlikely that is uh that this is going
to happen quickly which means it's not
going to happen at all once we are into
an election year nothing is going to
happen here meanwhile there is the real
possibility of a biden's tag flation
phil graham and mike sullivan writing
for the wall street journal
they said the white house continues to
insist that inflation will soon fade
away and the country will return to its
pre-pandemic prosperity but the biden
administration's regulatory agenda
virtually ensures that the post-pandemic
economy will be nothing like it was
before the mounting regulatory burden of
mr biden's executive orders his
regulators open hostility toward
america's economic system and the return
of progressive era antitrust enforcement
will stifle growth all the ingredients
will be present to turn the current
inflation into stagflation and this is
right okay as i've been saying before i
don't know how long the inflation is
going to last before it starts to even
out what i do know is that joe biden is
setting up a system that is going to be
a low growth system you know who admits
this joe biden
his actual projections for the next
decade are that we are supposed to grow
for the next decade like 1.6 1.7 a year
that is a zero growth policy considering
inflation even if it's at its lowest
point is gonna be like two percent
so what we are talking about is an
economy that is in
complete comatose state
and democrats are pushing it
according to phil graham and mike solon
america's experience with regulatory
access is recent and painful when the
subprime recession ended in mid-2009
economists predicted a strong recovery
in early 2020 in early 2010 the omb
projected 3.7 to average real gross
domestic product growth through 2016.
the cbo estimated 3.3 growth for the
same period the federal reserve expected
3.5 to 4 through 2014. instead we got
2.1
from 2010 to 2016.
now democrats are openly claiming it's
going to be below 2
for the next few years
democrats claim the nation suffered from
secular stagnation when subsequent
deregulation and tax cuts revived the
economy and the bite administration
needed justification for more stimulus
spending democrats suddenly decided
obama had not done enough to stimulate
the economy
so they're going to continue to double
down on all of this and you will get
people investing less in the economy why
would you invest in an economy where the
government seizes more of your money and
regulates your ability to control your
own business why would you do that
the answer is you're not going to do
that and all of this of course ties into
the alarmism the environmental alarmism
of this administration they're always
looking for an excuse to do the thing
they wanted to do anyway so anytime
something bad happens in life this
administration immediately jumps to we
need more regulation and we need more
top down control kovit more regulation
more top down control a tornado in
kentucky more regulation more top down
control it's always the same solution
okay if you went to a doctor and no
matter what symptoms you complained of
he offered you morphine you might start
to think that maybe the guy was a drug
pusher
well that is what you've got right now
you've got a government that is offering
the same solution to every problem so
either you believe that this solution
really is the gold standard the
all-purpose solution or it turns out
that these people are just pushing an
addictive drug of spending and
regulation regardless
of the
of of the first part of the statement
regardless of the contingency
the solution is always the same
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content